welcome back action Callie go ahead
action go ahead go welcome well I go
ahead joining me right now she's an
oscar-winning actress and he's a tiger
king loving actor and comedian together
they're helping feed health care workers
on the frontlines let's say hi doc
Tobias Spencer and Joel McHale yawn so
what's up guys can y'all hear me all
right everything I think it was
yesterday so you're back on thank you
for doing that but what do you know how
are you staying sane in you know
isolation trying to cook I literally
obviously I've given up on everything
look at my hair let go you're a liar you
know I stay sane by just remembering
that I was nominated for an Oscar and
[Laughter]
just being like I'm amazing no no I I go
to my favorite old western movie set and
I put a blanket over the window and I
sit in the corner of a wood building oh
wait yes you're in my favorite room hey
I'll have you know we had to fix this
room up Joel because we don't have
anything built here on our ranch so this
is like an unfinished cabin that we
played pretended like we're totally fine
and everything the other like if you
could see the other side of my camera
it's just unfinished walls
[Music]
you two sit in front of that tomorrow we
wanted to say happy 15th birthday
[Laughter]
amazing you look amazing
do we sing Octavia let's do it in around
happy birthday I got you a microphone
Joel you've been working with Tiger King
right you've been interviewing all the
people like printf likes right yeah no I
I can't I I'm holding onto the the
coattails of that documentary they asked
me to host the you know the kind of rap
the ketchup special and see where
everybody was that was agreeing to be on
camera and so they asked me a few days
before it aired and we quickly scrambled
together and got they had a bunch of
people ready to be interviewed so I you
know I had barely anything I I was just
happy to do it because I loved the
series and was fascinated by it and I
got to talk to a lot of the folks
involved and yeah it's it's but after
anything I've done in the business for
the last 20 years nothing compared to
the response of that I've never been a
part of anything that was that popular
ever
I'm not combined the soup and community
not even close to 140 minute special of
me going how's Oklahoma so that's that's
basically I'm watching The Waltons House
on the Prairie like things before times
of corona you are going to it you're in
a dark place if you're needing that cut
it you're like oh you're going way back
I need nostalgia for whatever I can go
ride my bike I like how I'm going back
before
Korona I was like you could done you
could have done er I mean that was 25
years ago but you decided to go back
almost 40 years how is your your podcast
going thank you for asking
it's with me and Ken Jong and it's
called the darkest cut timeline which is
a play on a community thing from a
couple of years ago which is now on
Netflix and and it's also because we're
in the darkest timeline of this kovat
thing and ken is a real doctor and his
wife is a real practicing doctor and he
knows he is very good at distilling
information down so we said well why
don't we do this because I'll talk to
you about what's going on with the virus
and then we can answer community
questions and so we talked about the
virus for about 10 minutes and then it's
an hour and a half of each other we just
insult each other and we've gotten to a
total of about four questions over four
episodes but right now it is literally
the number one podcast in the world it
is that's incredible that's not I don't
think of every time I think Kim Jong I
forget he's a doctor like and I'm yeah I
ran into each other several times and I
just think it's incredible that he has
that kind of knowledge and and also that
presence in like the entertainment
community just to kind of keep people's
eye and attention that's really cool I
think it's cool yeah I'm hilarious yeah
I know it's great that he left a
profession of helping people and making
people better so he could run around
make money no he's a really great he's
been a very close friend and now that
he's so old and it has a hard time you
know he's all he's that I'm helping him
you know it's like wait we already did
that sorry go ahead
nobody I forgot to ask how is Velma
how's your baby doing I've been looking
for all right well let's talk about the
important issue because I do you think
this is really awesome we all are doing
you're both helping health care workers
right now Joel you've been using your
Instagram page to help local restaurants
right again I don't know what you're
talking about Callie you're still okay
no yeah I've been going around to I'd
start I mean yeah we're going down to
local restaurants around me obviously
and in in Los Angeles going hey this is
an independently owned place obviously
it's suffering please come here get
takeout they have great french fries
they make a great steak they made a
great matzo ball soup and to just get
some sort of awareness of those places
because there are so many independent
businesses that are gonna go down and
the big guys the big corporations and
these chains yes it's gonna be very hard
on them but they're gonna be able to
survive but these guys they're not you
know paying they don't have to pay rent
right now but they they're gonna be on
the hook for it when this is all over
and it's gonna be very tough so anything
to support and then the way that
happened is that Melissa McCarthy and
Ben Falcone contacted me and said hey
we've been talking to Octavia Spencer
and then Octavia you take it from here
and my friends Leslie Feldman and we
were trying to figure out a way to do
exactly what Joel was doing feed the
front front the health care workers on
the front line and but help the
restaurants in our communities and in
some of those hospitals and then we
decided to join forces and then
something better happen front line foods
came along and they were doing what we
were doing on a larger scale and for so
many more people and they had a
volunteer army of over three hundred
people and five of us decided well we'd
like to join that army of over three
hundred people where one hundred
none of the proceeds go to all of the
restaurants to help keep their lights on
yeah and these are not it's not that
it's not that ya know restaurant is
don't they're not donating the food
they're being paid to do what they do so
from the person sweeping up the parking
lot to the surgeons to everybody because
you forget that there is routine there
are like people with cancer that need
their treatments and there are all sorts
of people that need medical assistance
and the you know our hospitals are
overwhelmed right now and so yeah it
gives a little bit of relief and they
thankfully they really appreciate it
except we let Octavia cook one of the
meals and this one person with the virus
is like don't you think I've suffered
enough but and that's actually
interesting because a lot of us
especially a lot of moms at home having
to like the kitchen try and figure it
out in the kitchen that's when we keep
making this [ __ ] look at our house but
we keep saying like you know I just want
to support my community right now and
order out but we make the joke I'm like
so tired of cooking because I'm not good
at it but this is such a clever thing
that came together with this like it's
so clever how it's helping everyone
involved it's a win-win even the people
getting to help you're not you're
getting to help people that helps your
spirit it helps to kind of pull out of
that dark place we can sometimes goats
when we're quarantined so that's that's
really incredible so this the
organization has actually raised over
1.6 million dollars donated over 50,000
meals and helped 135 restaurants across
the nation that's it's like so cool I
mean you - yeah I hope y'all I know
you're not doing it to like be proud of
it but that's really cool I know I did I
I think I'd probably like there was this
whole flurry of work while we were
trying to put this thing together it was
gonna be called comfort food 20
20 and then Octavia I don't know who
discovered frontline but they were like
wait big this is like we're in an
aircraft carrier showed up and said want
a ride and we like yes right now who
want to help like how could they help
and aid and what y'all are doing well
they could go to frontline food so I
would say if you don't have money to
give a simple prayer take some goes a
long way - well thank you so much John
Octavia for getting involved for more
info on how you can help go to frontline
foods org and look for Joel in a new
episode of The Twilight Zone on CBS all
access and as the voice of Johnny Cage
in the upcoming movie Mortal Kombat
legends scorpions revenge and also catch
Octavia in the Netflix movies self-made
inspired by the life of madam CJ Walker
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going